if you're no longer playing XCOM - and
thought hmm
zombies romance alien assassins loot and
cheesy yet catchy photo finishes would
bring you back someday then have some
good news
war of the chosen DLC adds that and
three new player controlled factions the
Reapers skirmishers and Templars we were
able to play as Reapers and skirmishers
in this gameplay clip of the lost and
abandoned mission where players are
first introduced to their uneasy
alliance all while being hunted by the
new chosen assassin in the zombie
infested wasteland to be fair the loss
Dom bees are equal-opportunity brain
eaters and will go after both your units
and the Advent as always likes and subs
are appreciated and keep an eye out for
some chosen cutscenes we'll put up in
addition to this video thanks everyone
let's get to it let's try and play nice
today people so advanced most brutal
captain comes to atone for his crimes I
am no longer that being I am a free now
taking off that helmet does not change
what you are
Reapers have long memories elder cracks
odd anytime the way I see it we have two
options join forces and kick the elders
off our world or kill each other here
and now the choice is yours
[Applause]
[Music]
no one has ever done that people are no
one shall ever do that again box prima
alvarez fasten relentless death that's
lost my kind butcher of free asset my
people face another like her
they are the undying advanced curse upon
us we must combine strength if we are to
have any chance of success you are
welcome to try
you're Reavers space of beings such as
this they appeared without warning years
ago had they not we would have already
regained our homes the elders will
extend throughout the universe one
moving to designate a position
I will reposition
[Music]
I'm on it
[Music]
moving to overwatch
I'm trusting you here
come get some moving there
is under my watch
orders confirmed on the move
reloaded
or overwatch no-one will cross no one
taught them how to move quietly
yourself
[Music]
very least
hanging there now
I am trusting you
on your order
Roger that
[Music]
it
[Music]
[Music]
moving the designated coordinates
I am on watch come get some
I stand ready you that you will not
suffer long
shall I bury your soldier that's my
stronghold where they can tell me of
your operations more freely
it looks like the chosen not one of our
soldiers into a daze we need to get
someone over there to help them get back
on their feet before that thing can move
in an attack humans do share an
admirable sense of loyalty even in the
face of certain death
[Music]
[Music]
if you take up
[Music]
grenade
don't go :
[Music]
I fail EUR is my own sure you can do
better
no I'm evade detection don't move you'll
be all right
moving to overwatch as your water
commander
finally a true strike
I'll get him next time you lack focus
we've got a soldier down get to him
before the chosen do
[Music]
[Music]
I had not expected this conflict to be
so exhilarating
you surprised me XCOM still the Elvis
will of that none survived this day I
cannot leave that to fortune the sonic
dispersal waves emitting from that pod
are Criss crossing a massive area
meaning that thing just rang the dinner
bell for every remaining lost in the
city an accurate assessment the entire
lost biomass seems to be converging on
this position then let's get you all the
hell out of there
firebrands enroute to the evac
coordinates now
get moving
they live no more there will come a day
when my people take back this place for
our own if they are all like you that is
a likely possibility
on the move
I go
moving to position
understood moving out
I will go
watch order confirmative covering that
I'm get some I won't let them pass
scanning they are moving
they're casual Yogi's work
no compromises
target neutralized detecting additional
lost converging near the evacuation
coordinates I advise caution it would
seem the lost are on to our strategy it
is the elders will that this alliance
fall it will take more than mere lost
for that to happen
it's down got no ammo rock'n'roll
good riddance
moving is ordered
good riddance my ammo is gone I must
reload
heading out
hustle target down dead in the water
here oh yeah
I guess that'll be okay
ever watch
closing on target position now
[Music]
to that position
or the moment we trial
go over
[Music]
firebrands in position but the evac
zones even hotter than we thought
running out of time here people tell her
to hold as long as you can we will be
there
enemies down planning tryout mo
justing site I'm all out ready to rock
enemy eliminated moving on target
location
moving out
[Music]
I'm still terminated
getting it done
[Music]
whatever
I'd never do that one scanning
and I will move
it is dead meat Apple reloading
[Music]
check it before you get you to this the
sheer magnitude of the biomass
converging upon this position is
staggering if our team does not evacuate
now
trust me doctor they know if you say so
[Applause]
no I do not intend to die this day
[Music]
[Music]
time to return home